so there was a really great quote you
know chomsky's not my favorite in the
world but he had this really great
moment on television decades ago where
he was talking to a reporter they were
interviewing him about his book and they
said to him he was basically explaining
that media Outlets will only forward
certain people who have a specific set
of values that line up with the networks
and the journalist becomes a little bit
indignant and they said are you accusing
me of not being sincere in my values and
Chomsky says no I believe you are
sincere what I'm telling you is you
wouldn't have this job if you weren't
you wouldn't have this job if you didn't
have those values right if you tow the
right line you're way more likely to
rise to the top this is what we were
saying earlier I mean if if you're a
right-wing person who works at a
left-wing Outlet you're going to keep
your head down and I got to be honest
with people you might want to say I can
be conservative at one of these
organizations to keep my head down you
either live what you believe or you
believe what you live at some point
you're going to be in simulated right
you are who you they say you're you are
a combination of The Five People You
spend the most time with